how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel today we are talking
about Sony's spider-verse now right now
the Cova 19 outbreak pretty much has the
whole entire world in quarantine and
unfortunately the entertainment industry
has taken a pretty big hit with the film
industry taking the biggest hit most of
the movie theaters around the world
right now have been closed until further
notice and even more unfortunate is that
most of the studios have halted
production on the movies that they were
currently working on right now
production on all Marvel movies have
basically come to a halt and the black
widow movie has been delayed and right
now there is no word on any new release
date now unfortunately last night Sony
has officially reported that Morbius
will be pushed back to next year 2021
and no new release date has been given
yet but the studio is most likely
waiting until they can find out further
information about the coronavirus and
how long we can expect it to be
prominent now of course many people are
super bummed about this but I do have
some really good news for you Sony has
stated that as of right now
venom 2 has not been moved but of course
that is always subject to change and
with movies dropping off left and right
being pushed back there's a very real
possibility that venom 2 could be next
however this was actually a very
strategic move done by Sony and the same
thing with other studios Marvel Studios
for example these are all strategic
moves pushing movies back and I'll
explain to you why as I mentioned right
now most of all of the theaters around
the world are closed and we don't know
when they're going to open back up and
right now the production on most films /
TV shows with Marvel specifically have
come to a halt as well and Sony is no
different and this pushes Marvel and
Sony's timelines for their movie
releases way back because if production
cannot begin soon on all of these
projects that these studios are working
on then their release dates are going to
get pushed back as well until eventually
there's going to be a time which is
really right now where there are going
to be no movies released for a very long
time
so essentially what Sony has just done
with the cancellation of Morbius
Ghostbusters and afterlife is fill slots
that they're going to need next year for
movies that they're going to have to
push
basically reordering a bit they're
released scheduled because like I said
venom two as of right now is still
scheduled to come out on October 2nd of
2020 and the same exact thing goes for
Marvel
Black Widow most likely won't come out
for another few months and this could
push the release date of the Eternals
back a little bit as well in fact the
entire phase for slate unfortunately
could all be pushed back by several
months it was reported a couple of weeks
back that it would not affect the
timeline of Marvel's phase four however
a lot has happened since then including
just last night the extension of the
lockdown in the United States at least
to be extended until the end of April so
right now unfortunately a lot is unknown
with the studio's so right now as sad as
it may seem
along with Black Widow we have to add
Morbius to the delayed pile of Marvel
movies but I'll be sure to keep you up
to date on everything that happens with
Black Widow Morbius and if anything
happens with venom 2 as well so be sure
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything happening in the film
industry in regards to Marvel films be
sure to stay safe out there and for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof